hey guys Pete here this will be my
watchman episode 9 trailer breakdown in
preview video sigh it's the last one the
episode title is see how they fly it was
written by Nick Cuse and Damon Lindelof
and directed by Frederick II Oh toy yay
or toy not sure how to pronounce his
last name but this is his first and the
only episode he directed in Watchmen
season 1 the episode description reads
everything ends for real this time
but this official promo from HBO does
say season finale rather than series
finale so we can hope that means that
there might be more stories in this
universe that'll come after they're not
completely closing the door we can hope
anyways I'm gonna break this down scene
by scene and that will involve spoilers
for everything that's happened
all the promotional materials that are
out there that we've seen after the
breakdown or discuss some theories about
the ending and speculate on what I'm
hoping we'll see the trailer opens with
an aerial shot of the Manor on Europa
inside his cell we see Adrian Veidt
opened up the pocket watch that he's had
with him since mr. Phillips gave it to
him as a gift and the post-credits scene
in the last episode we noticed that it
was one of the personal items he had in
his cell
along with his copy of the book fog
dancing that cuts to him looking out his
window at something we don't know what
he's looking at but it's safe to say
since this is the last episode that this
story on Europa will reach its
conclusion just a note in relation to
the timeline we know he was zapped there
in 2009 the cake in the last episode had
seven candles which means that he got
his hands on the horseshoe in 2016 or
three years before Angela woke dr.
Manhattan up in Tulsa so if he lined
that up at the regular timeline he was
probably getting that around the same
time that the white night happened in
Tulsa I'm fully expecting Adrian to be
physically present in Tulsa before the
end of the story I could be wrong about
that but it feels like that he's gonna
show up so I'll just leave that there
for now in the next shot we have someone
whose face is hidden behind goggles and
a face mask there's a reflection of a
structure which is most likely what we
see in the next shot that is the
entrance at Karnak in Antarctica which
we saw Manhattan
in Episode eight with the destroyed by
varium in the background this character
here in the episode 9 trailer pretty
much has to be lady true and this is
most likely her visiting Veidt
personally before dr. Manhattan does I
say that because I think they met face
to face before he went to Europa but we
also know that when true Industries was
taking over bytes companies members of
the byte enterprises Board of Directors
visited Antarctica to seek his blessing
on the sale that's when they found
Karnak to be empty and that's how he was
declared missing that was in 2012 the
evidence for them meeting face to face
being that he told John a little
elephant told him that he was on europa
and really who else would be going to
Antarctica besides lady true anyways the
trailer cuts to true with beyond right
after that they're holding hands in
present-day Tulsa and we can tell that
based on what lady T is wearing and it's
the same thing she had on when Angela
left her compound to go save cow and we
can imagine that this is all happening
right away because we had that countdown
to the clock going live in the
background an image of these two
together also showed up in the promo
photos for episode 9 from HBO along with
one other one where she is wearing a hat
and standing outside of the prayer booth
we saw laurie visit in episode 3 all of
these should be from pretty soon after
angela left and in the time leading up
to the millenium clock being activated
in the next scene it looks like beyond
is doing just that we see her standing
next to a control panel hitting buttons
with an assistant buyer side there's a
close-up of the panel that doesn't
really give anything away and then we
see a shot of the clock structure from
the ground below it's dark and we can't
see much but we can make out that it's
definitely the clock that we saw of them
building in previous episodes there's no
voiceover in this promo there's just a
ticking clock in the background
it starts off slow and builds up after
beyond turns the knob on her panel as
that happens images start to flash on
the screen faster as well there's a shot
of the newspaper guy we met in episode 2
he's turning to look at something
outside of his stand we can tell by the
light post in the background that this
is the same area where the prayer booth
and so maybe lady Tru was there in the
photo because she's gonna make a public
announcement about the clock remember we
saw her giving a speech but that was for
her employees only a couple episodes ago
then we see dr. Manhattan inside the
seventh Cavalry cage at the old JCPenney
he's alive and he looks fine other than
the fact that he's inside the cage which
they were building when Lori first
talked to Kean there that cuts to Angela
with the tear rolling down her cheek the
focus is tight on her face in a way that
we can't make out the background or
where she is
this could be at their house after he's
been transported or she could have made
her way to the hideout there's a quick
shot of a large door opening to a bright
light with three characters walking in
we see supplies and a snowmobile inside
which makes me think it's Carnac and
that two of the characters are probably
Adrian and Lady true if this is prior to
2009 the beyond clone would be pretty
young so it's not clear if that is who
the third person is or if it's somebody
else based on how it's shot it isn't
clear who any of them are really but it
does look like Antarctica and the hair
on the male character seems to match
fights next we have the first shot of
Lori with a 7th cavalry member standing
beside her she's probably exactly where
we last saw her and we can imagine that
she's watched her ex-boyfriend
dr. Manhattan being teleported into the
cage the 7th K soldier beside her is
probably looking glass I mean it's hard
to say with their masks but that's the
reason why he could actually pull that
off I think it looks like him if you
zoom in but if it's not I feel like it's
a pretty safe bet that he's probably
somewhere near by wearing a Rorschach
mask we see senator Keene in some sort
of chamber or enclosure without a shirt
on he looks serious and pleased going
off the face he makes and ready to see
if he can be turned into the next dr.
Manhattan the bumpers say the end is
nigh which is a callback to the sign
that Rorschach carried around with him
as Walter Kovacs when he wasn't wearing
his mask in the original comic there are
some quick shots of the Tulsa police in
action we see them driving down the
street we see them pull up shining their
headlights on 7th cavalry members
holding guns outside of a building which
is probably the JCPenney hideout we see
pirate Jenny and Red Scare
getting out of their Cruiser with rifles
drawn and have to imagine that they're
probably too late to stop whatever's
happening inside if they are at the
hideout but we realized they probably
could be at Angela's place as well
the next shot is Angela pulling up a
mask on a7k foot soldier and this looks
like it's happening outside of her house
she's probably trying to find out from
one of the survivors where they
transported dr. Manhattan with the
tachyon cannon after that we see a
Rorschach flipping open the cover on a
switch he's holding something that looks
like a remote control power switch
probably getting ready to start the
transfer from doctor blue to Senator
Kean this is followed by what could best
be described as a blue fireball coming
down from the Millennium clock it's not
clear what's happening here as this all
happens pretty fast but it does look
like the clock to me that's followed by
what looks like dr. Manhattan blowing up
inside the cage we see a large reaction
happening at the very least the shot is
from a distance and it looks like angela
is standing on the right of the cage and
the 7th cavalry are over on the left
side Angela being right there seems to
be confirmed in the closing shot we see
the light flare up in front of her and
that is where the trailer ends there's a
lot there but still plenty of mystery to
try to figure out what's going on I've
heard a lot of people saying that how
could they possibly tie this up in one
episode and I don't really see it I
think they've been knocking things off
the list answering questions the whole
time and I think that it feels pretty
manageable where we're at angela is the
center of the story we know what her
motivation is going into the finale she
wants to save dr. Manhattan that may or
may not be possible from what we got
from him it doesn't seem like he thinks
it's possible but I guess on the side
now she also wants to know if she was
the reason why her grandfather killed
Chief Judge I think it'll be easy for
them to answer those questions in the
finale the big mystery is lady true and
I feel like this is going to be a lady
true centered episode each of the
individual episodes has more or less
revolved around one character and their
story and I think this will be about
lady true and her plan it looks like
we're gonna see her go and meet Adrian
Veidt before he disappears the plan she
forms could be
influenced by what she learns from him
there they could be planning together
and like I said at the beginning I feel
like he's probably going to show up in
one way or the other so we're gonna get
answers to that we're gonna understand
how he influences the bigger story how
he's related to her plan and what her
plan actually is we see this giant blue
fireball coming down but they've been
pretty crafty with what they show us in
trailers and I just don't know that we
can draw any conclusions from that lady
true knows what the seven cavalry is
trying to do it seems strange that both
of these big events are scheduled for
the same night at the same time if
anything I think it's more likely that
she's using what they're doing to her
advantage will has to play some big part
in what she's planning he has
connections with Cyclops and those are
passed down through to the seventh
Cavalry so I don't actually think that
they are orchestrating what the seventh
Cavalry is doing but I think that
they're planning what they're planning
with that in mind and since they know
dr. Manhattan is probably going to be
destroyed it'll be interesting to see
how that all ties together the big thing
that everybody's been talking about
since episode 8 was dr. Manhattan
passing on his powers
it was definitely foreshadowed if you
think about the scene where he's talking
about the egg he says he could put his
powers into something organic like an
egg
if someone ate that then they could
inherit his powers I don't know why you
would make a point of bringing that up
if it's not going to play a part in the
end the 7th K is obviously trying to
transfer his power over to Senator Cain
I think that most of us could agree that
we don't think that the season is going
to end with a Manhattan like Senator
Kean running around making things easier
to be a white man in this world other
candidates to receive his powers have
been Topher he's a strange character and
many people have theorized that he could
be dr. Manhattan before the reveal and
that maybe he would be dr. Manhattan
after hooded justice is another
candidate of course although it's kind
of hard to figure out how that would
have came into Lady trues plan and then
the other candidate would obviously be
angela herself giving dr. Manhattan's
powers at the end the
he said is that he wouldn't pass on his
powers without consent he says that
right before he talks about passing them
off but perhaps that's not important
because all of those people might just
accept that if given the opportunity it
seems strange to think that they would
kill off dr. Manhattan the original dr.
Manhattan but it looks like things are
heading in that direction the question
there is what happens if there is
someone who is the new dr. Manhattan at
the end is there an ending in that I
don't know but I don't want all of these
characters to die and Manhattan's powers
to die along with it so let me know what
you guys think about that in the
comments the main things are mostly
expecting to have answered are how does
Angela and dr. Manhattan's love story
end why did her justice come back to
Tulsa after all this time and how did he
hook up with lady true what brought lady
true to Tulsa and why did she build the
millenium clock and raise a clone of her
own mother there will she be able to
follow through with her plan and how is
this supposed to make the world a better
place I mean the end of the show should
recreate the feeling that you had when
you first finished reading the book
something big will happen and we
probably won't exactly be sure how we
feel about it I think that they can do
that based on where we're at and of
course there's gonna be stuff like we're
gonna understand why he was walking on
water why there were eggs and everything
and all the stuff that's been
foreshadowed and hopefully we'll get
answers to a lot of the smaller
questions that came up in the process of
the show because there are a lot of
questions I'm thinking about making
another video before the finale about
the questions that I would like to see
answered so if you have questions like
that it could be small things even that
aren't super important to the big story
leave those in the comments and I'll
think about trying to get that out
before the finale airs for that reason
I'm gonna leave it there let me know
what you think in the comments about
this trailer let me know what questions
you'd like to see answered in the finale
are there any questions you'd like to
see go unanswered I mean there has to be
a little bit of mystery left at the end
right what do you think's going on in
all these scenes I just went through how
do you want to see the story and please
like the video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already thanks for watching we'll talk
to you soon